c'est l'une des dernières dispositions
du projet de loi contre le séparatisme
l'article 44 facilite la fermeture des
lieux de culte ou sont prononcés des
discours de haine
il vise directement des imams qui
prêchent serait la violence dans
certaines mosquées
le représentant de l'état dans le
département où apparaît le préfet de
police peut prononcer la fermeture
temporaire des lieux de culte dans
lesquelles les propos qui sont tenus les
idées ou théories qui sont diffusées ou
les activités qui se déroulent provoque
à la haine ou à la violence envers une
personne ou un groupe de personnes ou
tendent à justifier ou encourager cette
haine ou cette violence une disposition
déjà prévues dans le cadre de la lutte
antiterroriste
récemment elle avait inspiré la
fermeture de la mosquée de pantin en
seine-saint-denis après le meurtre de
l'enseignant samuel pâtit mais cet
article 44 est critiquée à gauche
il lui est reproché de mettre en place
une forme de punition collective de la
communauté musulmane
à droite on estime que cet article ne va
pas assez loin
autre disposition polémique de ce projet
de loi celle concernant l'instruction à
domicile l'article 21 ans pose le
principe de la scolarisation obligatoire
de l'ensemble des enfants aujourd'hui
soumis à l'obligation d'instruction soit
les enfants âgés de 3 à 16 ans il ne
pourra être dérogé à cette obligation de
fréquenter un établissement
d'enseignement publics ou privés que sur
autorisation délivrée par les services
académiques pour des motifs tirés de la
situation de l'enfant est définie par la
loi
une possibilité qui devra être soumise à
autorisation
mais cela pourrait bouleverser le
quotidien de nombreuses familles ayant
opté pour ce mode d'instruction soumis
aux députés depuis le 1er février
l'examen du projet de loi confortant le
respect des principes de la république a
nécessité 135 heures de débats en
commission spéciale plus de 300
amendements ont été adoptés par
l'assemblée nationale le texte sera
soumis à un vote solennel mardi avant
d'être examiné par les sénateurs